[Musique]
si tu t'imagines si tu t'imagines
fillette si tu t'imagines que ça va que
ça va que ça va durer toujours la saison
des as et un désert saison des amours ce
que tu te goures fie à ce que tu te
goures
si tu crois pas dit si tu crois que ton
teint de rose bataille de gamme des
minions biceps des ongles des mailles la
cuisse de naphte ont pilé g si tu crois
petit que ça va que ça va que ça va
durer toujours ce que tu te goures film
c'est que tu es de moore
les beaux jours s'en vont les beaux
jours de fête
soleil et les planètes tournent tous
sans
toi ma petite tu marges tout droit vers
ce que tu vois pas
très sournois s'approche la ride véloce
la présence de graisse
le menton triplé le muscle avachi alors
que hegel
les rose les roses roses de la vie et
que leurs pétales sur la mairie talent
de tous les bonheurs
alan kay cueille si tu le fais pas
c'est que tu te goures fillette viêt
c'est que tu te couvre
[Musique]